last week I asked you guys to make a
green screen computation I recorded
myself look at this how can you not be
creative with this oh boy I can't wait
to see all the submissions oh look there
are nine you're all a bunch of crybabies
I think I have the fan base on YouTube
consisting more and more and mostly of
just a bunch of whiny sons of guns
I can't swear and it pisses me off
whatever you know what I don't care
let's just let's just jump into it okay
ugly fish do call play-doh brush make
sure they are made of tiny about it on
the episode it's a completion date
cougar in Finland we have a button to
thank the bus driver and we're leaving
no no that can't be real now honestly
it's not real right I am not prepared to
wield such power what happens if you
don't press it I have so many questions
are they located all across the bus or
is it in a spot where the bus driver
will see it how does it signal the bus
driver does it play a little thank-you
song I need to know more information
Finland please provide more information
one of those countries that never did
anything ever dr. Phil what is the why
and why do people keep asking me to host
it let's get dr. Phil to host the why
come on guys if this video hits 500
Billy likes then dr. Phil has agreed
with me to perform on a concert may 25th
it's gonna be the biggest celebrity
concert for real guys everyone tweet dr.
Phil that would be a trick I made him
angry we have ascended to phase two
you have too much power for any single
man getting on the Y this many times in
the row getting met why do you guys keep
thumbing up this don't make me swear
just stop I'm putting an end to this
what is this background even everything
about this annoys me okay just stop
forgive me for asset I seen this one
come on it's good can I show this mean
what's the pretty pie version of this
that's what I want to see y'all
know what to do never what the hell is
it say stop putting secret messages in
my videos oh my god I so annoying we did
it very nice everybody a nice little
departure gift for our guys Stefan Karl
rest in peace
ok alright finally finally we have some
green-screen competition edit look at
the hit why I don't remember filming
this
[Music]
there we have professed
[Music]
if that that has gone to the Brotherhood
of the virgins this meeting must be
strike down
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's great thank you kindly
turns out you guys aren't completely
useless how about that give yourself a
pat on the back that's amazing
new pity pie for tonight emotes okay
you just got trolled licked hard yeah a
big style baby looks like you just got
trolled and mixed I'll kill me I don't
wanna be here I want nothing to do with
this
can we add Beauty pie to for tonight 500
million likes if we can make it happen
I said modest goals on this channel
don't worry about it that's great
actually though it it very nice so you
think you're better than me oh yeah
bring it on yeah
you can't redeem can penetrate my
defenses
donate the bomb feel like good job
oh I will spare no thoughts
[Music]
hi-yah I've mastered the art of the
swordsmanship incredible edit Wow I'm so
impressed nothing will stand in the way
of me and my virginity
this probably takes so much time as well
actually live footage from the Brighton
Pier everybody this is not green-screen
my girlfriend told me she will marry me
if I get two K comments on this post
police help guys please guys help me
marry my girlfriend by commenting on
this video guys guys so this video gets
xx I mean I do the same thing I don't
really a moderator turn off commenting
for this post
destruction a hundred some people just
want to watch the world burn martyr
actually saved the guy's life
I can relate a joke a joke everybody
alright moving on
RTX are r-tx are do you god damn picket
you look sexy is it just me or is
Pikachu looking very attractive
holy moly Misty's looking very very sexy
and look at that look at Ash Ketchum
Brock Obama look Missy brocco bomb dr.
Phil dark man now I'm just gonna let her
at anything I mean it's not you like you
lose so he doesn't laugh come on this is
a good meme I like this mean template
start a family find a prestigious job be
happy upload this image to die instantly
thumbs up this video to die instantly
everybody can we hit Mass General No
okay when a body part falls asleep
that's pretty accurate that's pretty
accurate right there kid
she mighta didn't ask for this level of
accuracy why is that huh can we get a
Vsauce
20 minute video explaining this
phenomena that would be great outfits
that give you PTSD okay yeah I know I
can't wear the stupid kitty things
anymore
which is more shut up in the comments
you should have added the beard to this
outfit I love those kitty things
can I bring them back when you think
you're going to be the top meme of
September then that we started doing
something bad to some gender swap dragon
bongo cat still has a good chance what
do you guys think
come on Bongo just bung go away this is
so sad can we it's the only way it's the
only way we can save bog okay when
you're meme always get a uploads so you
decide to make a meme about your memes
getting aid about boats all the time but
you still get eight uploads whack and it
gets 14,000 14,000 up boats everybody
this is all it takes to be part of the
PD PI's submission subreddit everyone
submit your meme today guys new intro
for me really oh damn this is the jig
oh oh oh oh oh
[Music]
is it gonna see is it really the Matlin
oh my
dang damn it's time to start is what he
said damn alright official intro huh
Alex I don't play anything cuz it'll get
copy strike yeah that's right I have
actually had videos game copy strike
because I like to starts playing like a
two second pink lip YouTube 2018 it's
you know what don't go off with a Tenjin
Ryan clearly that's amazing thank you
barman I'll use the next video
honestly the most professional will
looking one and this ones are for all P
series peer hub excellent guys I'm
announcing a new website I think you
guys are really gonna like it
fact cats have nine lives this is nine
apparently Felix need to make nine meme
reviews about Bongo cat the killing all
right
that's another one you're down to seven
can take it that's English apparently
remember these 10 this video get 1
million dislike Kenda City hit Amelia
likes can this is he okay I mean what
else could I possibly do he could do can
my pin coming get 1 million likes okay
Brock that's a bad okay alright chao-li
accepted this is so sad I used to play a
lot of tennis nine-year-old let's get P
to play tennis you know what I actually
also played golf and I used to be a
sailing instructor that's right I'm a
man of many talents because you guys are
nine year olds you like this story I
used to be a sailing instructor for a
bunch of kids right a bunch of
nine-year-olds and at the beginning of
the license and never almost like can I
can I say oh good Felix I want to sail
with Felix and then at the end of the
week because we had a super stormy week
and we kept kept capsizing because these
stupid children doesn't know how to sail
for some for some reason and then at the
end of the week it was like no one's to
sail with Felix that everyone was like
this it was awkward moment ever like no
one liked me I'm a great instructor okay
these stupid children didn't Tim for
nine-year-olds I hate manga/anime
Netflix adaptation T series adaptation
dancer
I'll use my special move against
t-series watching meme review in front
of the European Parliament
god damn mrs. Savage excellent job mr.
hero sensei - good job everyone a round
of applause for heroes sensei - that's
it for this week's love why do -
favorite show everybody if you enjoyed
this video smash like it subscribe if
you haven't already submit a meme
give it a go give it a try it doesn't
seem to matter what I tell these guys to
do you'll just do whatever you want
anyway so just do what you do um this is
not a big deal or whatever I'm having
some problem with my videos I don't know
if it's a technical issue or whatever
I'm trying to sort it out with YouTube
but it seems like they're not publishing
properly I know it's such an old mean
but they're not publishing properly two
sub boxes I to my own channel so I know
it's not working properly because I'm
not getting notified myself and I don't
know it's just a bunch of annoying stuff
that you have to deal with behind the
scenes that can be really stressful and
annoying but I notice a lot of really
nice supported comments in the last two
videos and it really cheered me up when
I was really annoyed so I just want to
say I appreciate you guys always being
so supportive I know it's like a meme or
whatever that I'm so annoyed all the
time but I see you guys and I appreciate
you and I wanted you to I wanted to know
that so thank you very much and I'll see
you tomorrow goodbye